Dave McMenamin has been covering ESPN's
the NBA beat since 2005 he's a senior
NBA reporter for ESPN since 2014 he's a
favor to the show and he's back here how
are you Dave I'm great I'm not one of
you guys our body Brockman is is he's
tight we're locked in Dave let's go
buddy he's locked in on Argentina I love
it all right so let's get to it what
what can you tell us about the
communication between the Cav's and
LeBron so far Dave it hasn't occurred
LeBron's on vacation with the family
right now there's been no communication
with LeBron or LeBrons people and the
Cavs since the Cavs season ended last
Friday you know just about a week ago
and that's not necessarily a bad thing
that's that's not a surprise that's not
like a change in the wind
in terms of where LeBron is going to go
I wouldn't read that as a negative
development but this is the way LeBron
James has just decided conduct his
business he is basically sending a
message as I'm interpreting it to the
cab that hey you have a chance to get me
of course but you got to go take care of
business
make the franchise look as attractive as
possible as you can then when it's time
I'm gonna reach out to you and you're
gonna show it and show me why I should
come back to the Cavs to play for you in
2018 2019 and beyond so what can they
can tonight actually be part of that
puzzle Dave with an eighth overall
selection I mean it one normally the
number a pick in a draft isn't a
franchise changer
I don't even say this year's draft is
that much more teeth in a normal year
was eight carries more value the Cavs oh
they like what they can get at number
eight they believe that there's a
handful of guys that will be available
they can choose from that will satisfy
something that was missing from the Cavs
roster turned this last playoff run was
you know in terms of either a guy with
playmaking ability or playmaking ability
and defensive switch ability or
defensive toughness and some shooting
ability like some combination of those
skills that the entire
have collection of talents lacked as
they made their way to the fourth
straight NBA Finals they think they can
get and when you're a luxury tax
strapped team like the Cavs have been
because Dan Gilbert has spent more than
any other owner in the last four years
to try to keep the roster together for
LeBron James sometimes you actually have
to get a young talent that's the most
important thing to do not trade the pick
that doesn't mean they're not gonna
listen to offers tonight if one comes
down the pike but they're going into the
draft intending to draft a guy that they
can bring on their team back well what
about making a big splash tonight moving
up wouldn't that be something that would
cut this right a vacation time for
LeBron T here that's the interesting
thing to me is that you know and I can
only go by the other reporter that we
have here and you know Jonathan Turley
does a great job for ESPN and you know
he's reporting seven teams are in play
for the bestest pick at number four in
none of those seven teams of the Cavs
and so it makes me wonder okay
it has not data damaged by someone such
you know someone who could be there for
some like AM Obama or Wendell Carter
etcetera etcetera that they don't think
that player be that much better than the
guys I think they get a Michael Porter
Jr Trey young Collin Sexton J Alexander
out of Kentucky
etc now maybe they are one of the 18s or
maybe they're waiting to the last minute
to wow Memphis with an offer or maybe
they want to go a bit higher but to me
that means that they are they either one
of two things either they aren't totally
enamored by any one guy or the guy that
they really like they they are pretty
sure it will be available for them at
8:00 well what about the idea of
shooting their shot with the Spurs for
Kawhi and how that might play into
tonight or what the team can do with
Kevin Love because he's there I would
agree I assume you would agree they're
most attractive piece that they would
have to throw out there right Dave right
yeah absolutely
until I reported yesterday that
heading into the draft the Cavs are not
actively shopping Kevin Levin and they
would have interest in bringing Kevin
back to the roster next year regardless
of whatever decision LeBron makes by the
future
now part of that is they did call this
first and they dangled what they had in
their coverage was basically Kevin Love
and the number eight pick is the two
most valuable valuable pieces and they
got the impression that's not anywhere
close to what they need to acquire Kawhi
and if you think about it like you'd go
oh man well you know the ones like the
package for Kyrie Irving was that much
better the package for Paul George was
that much better but the difference is
Kyrie Irving Paul George 10 to 15
players in the league like that's where
they rank in the range number 10 to 15
is that range Kawhi Leonard's 1 to 5 and
the Spurs are giving out the vibe that
they want a much more robust package to
part ways with Kawhi and and the Cavs
recognize that you know we don't have
those assets so we're not going to be a
player for Kawhi and with that then
we're we're looking at it like we're not
going to keep shopping Kevin just to
shop him we would shopping for quiet but
if we're not knock why we're gonna hold
on to the guy Dave McManaman here on the
Rich Eisen show so then what could
possibly be Cleveland's game plan to
tell LeBron to stay I mean other because
if they don't have the pieces to go get
Kawhi to bring them then you figure they
don't have the pieces to bring anybody
else that might create the super team
they're they're capped out I mean
they're gonna be luxury texts regardless
of whether LeBron returns Dave I mean
whoever they choose number 8 overall
that that that's gonna be the most
attractive new piece for them to say to
LeBron to stay I mean is that it what we
should you know I mean so there's a
couple things here one I think part of
the appeal to stay is LeBron we've
changed our roster every year you know
the first year was Timofey Mozgov and
Iman Shumpert and JR Smith and then was
Channing Frye and it was Kyle Korver and
then obviously all the trades that
occurred this year in February
completely changing the team we're going
to continue to be aggressive and do that
and we're going to take on extra money
at the trade deadline if we have to do
that but because of our luxury tax
situation which you're well aware of a
LeBron smart enough to understand that
but you know this summer we may not get
the piece right away and we'd like you
have some patience with us and look at
our track record and doing that
hopefully the young pieces develop and
you know there's an avenue that you know
well they also have a couple trade
exceptions so they're confused and then
beyond that there's an avenue that has
been discussed much but based on dance
spending habits I don't think it's out
of the realm of possibility that you
know they would pursue a buyout of one
of the bad contracts they have that
would free up them in the future a
little bit more now is that a perfect
solution absolutely not and that's why I
think the the one team that the Cavs
probably have to worry about the most
would be the Lakers because the Lakers
right now have the maneuverability and
the young assets to basically turn that
team into a blank canvas and it can look
completely different the first week of
July than it does right now when it
comes to LeBron to make its decision but
outside of that the Cavs basically all
they can go on is track record patience
and the obvious ease the tie to the
Northeast Ohio community having played
for the Capitol about 15 seasons in the
league and probably also the narrative
card they can play that hey LeBron you
stay with the Cavs it's only positive
for you no one criticizes you if you end
up with a cap for us your career you go
somewhere else really anywhere else if
you don't win your legacy can take a hit
do you really want that 16 years in the
league 34 years old to take that risk in
that burden I don't know Dave I mean
what do you really take a hit for him
saying you know I I love Kevin Love it
was great playing with him there we won
one for the land
you know Tristan Thompson's a warrior
you know I'm not saying this is a sort
of thing he would say publicly but you
know the guy I'm depending on didn't
know what the freaking score was I mean
seriously
right so there's an out there but so I
think he would never be indepted by the
Lakers if he didn't win championship and
we agree on that they just wouldn't I
mean look Kobe Bryant already has his
head on a target seemingly trying to you
know plant plant seeds about well you
know you understand it become the Lakers
it's all about championship Houston
Rockets the perception is that they're
so close to the Warriors in my opinions
are really not I think the Warriors were
going through their own kind of stuff
during the playoffs and did not play
nearly as well as they're capable of
against the Rockets and then they
figured it out against the Cavs and then
you know Philly you go to play with a
bunch of young players you know and
who's to say they're ready to perform
you know those guys have won one playoff
series combined who's to say they're
ready to perform when LeBron is still in
the prime of his prime so I don't think
there's a perfect solution out there and
all of them you would have the idea of
well he's going there to try to win a
ring and if he doesn't win a ring he
failed there with the cab that doesn't
exist so last one for you Dave do we
know what when do we know when the
orders up is LeBron gonna give the Cavs
a first shot when do we know when that
that actually begins to be hammered out
it's a good question I I mean again as I
mentioned he's on the couch with the
family don't know for sure when that
will occur June 29th is a date to look
at right now it's about eight days from
now LeBron has to either pick up his
option for next season by then or opt
out and officially become a free agent
at which point I imagine that would be
kind of the start of the clock and it
wouldn't surprise me if the Cavs and
LeBron is camp open up communication
that day because obviously the Cavs I
mean
LeBron inform that decision and from
there it would be okay what we doing
from here and then
let's hear it hear it out enjoy the
draft Dave will chat next week and
throughout this whole process really
appreciate it that's Dave McMenamin at
MC te na at McTell the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience